welcome to the scream queens wardrobe
trailer my character was a security
guard
last season I got nothing excuse me I
work for the FBI now boom it's a new
sheriff
there's a lot of hotness on the set now
between John Stamos and Taylor Lautner
little eye candy never heard nobody
sorry is between your two jobs if he
does buy time for family and thank
goodness for FaceTime good morning how
are you behave learn something today and
don't come home with a boyfriend just
like her scream queens role mom me feel
ace down the law at home but her new gig
on Showtime's masters of sex allows her
to let loose it's called masters and sex
well read them because they have a lot
of sex on this show and when I first got
this job I was like wait a minute am I
will have to have sex should I get a
boob job like what is happening and no
you're gonna be fine
I've been here for ten minutes it's like
hey we want to say for you to have sex
what going down today
oh I'll Drive you here every day myself
but you were absolutely not
NVC is just 24 days away from finding
out if she'll take home any gold for her
role on getting on she's moved with
other nominees at the Emmys peer
reception what can I do to you about the
dress
you gotta make this right but win or
lose nothing conceal this golden moment
she shared washing dishes at a party
with Oprah or winning here to start
cleaning up and Oprah says but no no no
you don't have to do that I said ma'am
yes I do my mother would not have it and
so she was like well we're all and they
mixed thing I know everybody is in the
kitchen cleaning up and it's a party and
I was just looking at her like my god I
love you